[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale tv
leçon spéciale pour débutants avec le
maître international féminin nino
maisuradze et bonjour ni nos jours
alors aujourd'hui on va voir un match
important essentiel qui est le mat avec
la dame donc c'est un des mottes
élémentaire qu'il faut absolument
connaître parce que c'est avoir une dame
ces grands avantages et ne pas aboutir
ce serait catastrophique voilà donc si
vous avez une dame de plus évidemment il
faut arriver à mater parce que le but du
jeu d'échec c'est de maths et si vous
pouvez pas mater en fin de partie alors
vous avez une dame de plus c'est à
désespérer c'est pas la peine de jouer
alors il vaut mieux apprendre d'abord
comment mater avec des pièces davance et
notamment quand on a une dame d'avant ce
qui peut arriver même qui arrive souvent
mais ça arrive souvent
alors on va voir ça tout de suite dans
notre exemple on regarde et on a mis
donc le minimum de pièces il ya les
droits évidemment est donc une dame
blanche donc c'est évidemment les blancs
qui vont essayer de mater les droits des
noirs devant eux de défendre alors
comment on va faire pour mater alors
explique la technique donc il est
technique il faut dire on ramène le roi
donc le roi et la dent ont collaboré
entre guillemets et on s'entraidait ils
vont essayer de ramener le roi comme
c'est très typique d'ailleurs vers le
courant ouvert la dernière rangée
donc il faut amener le roi vers le coin
ou vers l'est vers la dernière rangée
oui soit avec cette méthode est plus 9
aux tirs 1 de faire la même chose donc
faire écouler le roi vers la vers le
coin dernier ranger uniquement l'anglais
dame et le roi va arriver jusqu'au
dernier moment pour faire maths et ça il
faut dire que la dame et le clp son
échec qui peuvent faire reculer le roi
tout seul tout seul avec une pièce qui
peut faire ça tout ça alors comme on
fait alors par exemple ici on a
plusieurs possibilités
1 parce que pourquoi j'ai dit plusieurs
possibilités ont juste réfléchir où on
préfère faire régler le roi vert
huitième rang j'ai ouvert par exemple si
colonna colonna achètent ces potions
prendre simple et on veut régler le roi
avant le 8e rang j'ai je peux commencer
même par damas quatre c'est pas
forcément le coup au plus merveilleuses
mais c'est un coût d'un mach 4 simple je
veux amener le roi de ce côté là donc je
mets la dame en h4 donc ici j'empêche
déjà le roi c'est ça
déjà de venir ici il peut pas malade je
veux amener quelque part par là
oui donc imaginer que le roi attend
parce que s'ils rient culte à nyon tout
de suite nous aussi circulent tout de
suite notion faire dame jeu 5
ici par exemple et encore une fois vous
voyez on a déjà accordé limiter les cas
ce possible et leroy - sow manquait donc
solide et donc maintenant imaginons
qu'il fait froid ces six d'abord mettre
en examen simple tout ceci sans fin
donc l'idée roissy c'est quoi il se dit
par exemple je parle très cool et donc
je vais attendre sur le même rangée voix
parce que si la dame fait check up je me
ramène projet le centre et ça va plus
difficile d'augmenter lé les faux
typique des débutants ils sont très
attirés par faire les échecs alors que
ça sert pas à grand chose ici si vous
faites un chien com se défend bien dire
le roi ou à s'échapper vers le centre
donc c'est pas le goût alors 11 explique
comment donc faire reculer les nomme
uniquement le roi uniquement
d'ingrédients alors vous faites ici
dames et cinq dames ici ici et pourquoi
ici donc on garde le contrôle ici le roi
à ne plus approcher les 400 rencontres
des six ont marqué ou à des sit in y
monter oui comment les dames à contrôler
les gaz donc soit il va réguler soit le
à rester sur le même rangé le plus
logique c'est vrai qu'il reste sur le
même rasé un grand p 6 on voit bien
aussi comment la dame
limite regardez le petit espace
maintenant qu'elles auront assez de plus
en plus serrés là par exemple 3 soit sur
17 / b 6
par exemple en b 6 l'idée donc rester
sur 6e ranger n'est pas dégradé sa
position mais là d'un mois sur le roi
regarder mais sur ça veut pas dire placé
juste à côté parce qu'il va prendre
notre dame pas ici parce que ici up mais
celle là c'est là c'est nul parce que
personne n'est pas gagné ces parties
nulles
donc c'est pas ben là c'est pas donné à
dawn juste raté il doit avoir une case
libre entre entre le roi et dans et vous
suivez le roi comme ça voilà on dit
souvent qu'il faut mettre la dame à une
distance de cavaliers du rouge et or en
ligue 1 c'est comme si un cavalier
pouvait sauter la regarder la dame et à
distance de kabylie le roi évidemment ne
pas prendre la dame et regarder toutes
les cases que la dame contrôlée qui est
regardé le roi de moins en moins d
espace
mais ce qui nous intéresse surtout c'est
l'occase à 55,6 en guest et 6 donc voilà
deux mois enlevez juste invite bessette
pour montrer et aussi des 8-17 pour
montrer exactement surtout les casqués
et voire même de 6 on va le voir sur
tous les cas qui nous intéresse pour
délit de wes et surtout ses quatre cases
la wii qui n'est permet au roi ni monter
et ni venir heures le centre alors il
peut s'échapper ici voilà par exemple il
va s'échapper comme ça pour rester dans
le centre et là on va faire quoi bas on
va poursuivre avec le distancer
cavaliers comme des fonds donc oui
encore une fois ça et 17 et contrôle et
donc c'est important
chaque fois on fait une sorte onglet
toujours des justes pas comment décrire
aux joues ce mur où le roi n'avait pas
traversé les cas sans pourtant pour lui
si je crois bien bessette on continue ou
elena mot consent evolis par dylan moins
en moins de gaz sera oui vous commencez
à comprendre ne presque plus de case oui
maintenant imaginons qu'ils aillent
encore ici oui par exemple on revient
encore la wii alors des le droit
regardez il ya plus de cases même la
casa 8 il a pas une seule case parce que
on arrêterait s'est rétréci ces
territoires de roi noir
donc là on va faire la même chose et par
contre il faut pas se tromper sur le
vernis
la silla âmes tarder empêche le roi noir
complètement de bouger il a plus qu'une
case dont ils réussissent et le reste il
faut pas faire d'erreur là elle l'a très
important de ne pas se tromper
là il est temps de ramener le roi et
fermathe euros pour amener donc juste
derrière ce compte
une fois que le rwanda le grand parce
que si vous faites comme ça l'est encore
moins de 15 d'ici vous faites encore ça
peut-être vous ne connaissez pas encore
mais on appelle sa patte expliqué dans
les autres cours aussi ça signifie quoi
le roi il a plus de casse et il peut
aller nulle nulle part vous voyez donc
vous pensez comme moi c'est parfait vous
pouvez dire j'ai fait maths mais ne
s'est pas le match pat c'est obtenir des
points pour chaque joueur donc faire nul
parfois c'est l'un de deux millions et
demi comme c'est pourquoi parce que
différents mondes mat le le neurone et
pas souhaité chèque le roi des phares en
échec il peut pas bouger ses pattes et
là c'est nul alors donc il faut pas
aller jusque là donc faut s'arrêter
quand vous avez mis le roi dans le coin
trop s'affoler faut s'arrêter là où il a
deux cases il a plus de cas mais il peut
bouger et pendant qu'il va bouger entre
ces deux cas cela il suffit de laisser
la dame là pour qu'ils puissent plus
bouger on va ramener leurs prix parce
qu'il faut pas donc emprisonné le roi
sans échec parce que ça va donner match
nul donc là vous approchez tout
simplement un contrepoids donc les eaux
noires sont obligés de venir les noirs
sont anciens prisonniers ils ont le sait
le coup faire croît donc à gauche à
droite c'est à dire à 8 p 8
en attendant et vous tranquillement ou
rapprocher à autre proie regardée comme
une approche il est menacé à ce roi hop
et mes gars ayant appris roye b 8 seller
et donc les vous avez plusieurs matches
possibles alors par exemple ça ça c'est
matt et trey chapelle nulle part puisque
le roi adverse ne peut pas aller sur ces
casse puisque le roi blanc les contrôles
donc regarder le roi blanc contrôler ces
cases donc c'est interdit et la dame
fait un échec ici est donc le roi et
échec les maths donc ça c'est le premier
match par exemple d'armes 17
aussi il deuxième map possible mais
c'est atypique avec la dame
voilà on écrase le renoir est écrasé par
la dame
regardez qui contrôle tout les cas c'est
le baiser de la mort ah oui je ne sais
pas comment vous allez
essayez de la morale donc c'est la dame
qui écrivent qui fait un baiser mortel
et puis évidemment la dame est
imprenable puisque c'est pour ça qu'on a
monté le roi le roi protège évidemment
la dame donc on peut pas prendre la dame
puisque on se mettrait en échec du roi
adverse
voilà donc simplement seimat pour
revenir si avec un seul coup ses fins
par exemple si c'était même si vous
faites n'importe quel coup condamné
cette par exemple même et c'était très
haut noirs ici et là aussi c'est très
simple à faire maths parce que regarder
oui par exemple dans 308 avec dams et
c'est par exemple c'est toujours voyez
où vous n'êtes pas obligés à voir le roi
en face ça aussi ça man show c'est comme
ça aussi
aulas et mat c'est le montage des dames
c'est une pièce très puissante
combinaison touré fout tant que le roi
protège la pièce le roi adverse ne peut
pas prendre la pièce donc ça peut être
aussi tellement à noter un joli matelas
aussi différent s'il est très jolie
aussi celui-là puisque la le noir le roi
est pris à part les deux pièces il est
pris ici évidemment par la dame alors
dame fait un échec ici donc toutes ces
cases sont prises par la dame est ici
par contre c'est le roi blanc qui
contrôlent à la fois la case v7 ici et
la casse c'est 7 et la maison le roi
blanc ne contrôle pas mais c'est la dame
encore voilà donc il ya c'est un beau
matt aussi celui ci donc a remarqué qu'
il est impossible qu'un fer match aller
de notre roi quand on en parlait de
faire uniquement quelques chocs la dame
on parle de faire reculer le royaume uni
qu'on a eu la dent mais c'est impossible
de faire maths sans roi donc on va voir
un autre va revoir ce match quand même
on va l'emmener voir ici donc damage 4
regardez comme la dame ici s'approche
ici ça c'est une erreur évidemment donc
il faut jouer comme des cinq hop hop hop
année le roi n'a plus qu'une case up et
voilà ça y est la plus de cases et on
ramène le roi ça c'est une erreur
évidemment puisque la livrée pattes donc
on ramène le roi cool ou laisser les
noirs à avoir un cool dans leurs
réserves pour que la partie n'était
remet pas par les maths ou alors
différents voici musulmans atteindre
ici il ya aussi matt comme ça donc on
notera quand même une autre méthode tout
de suite ramener le roi et après vous
pourrez choisir quand vous voulez il ya
certains donc par exemple on peut
parfaitement également touché très
rapprochés on ramène le roi donc ça
c'est une autre méthode
on va on pousse pas le roi avec la dame
et on va céder directement du roi blanc
ici voilà donc par exemple les noirs
jouent le coup droit ici par exemple
voilà tant que là par exemple qu'on paie
quand même fermé il ya plusieurs fois ci
le parisien tf6 aussi c'est possible
même si l'idée c'est quoi de contrôler
maximum des cases donc si on me
dérangeait et collomb pour le roi par
exemple voilà par exemple
là on rapprocher le roi donc on l'a
maintenant on empêche regarder alors
faut bien comprendre comment le roi
contrôle des cases
oui toutes ces cases ici sont interdites
la dame maintenant regarder interdit
aussi ses cases là et s'il faut le voir
ça faut voir effectivement ses couleurs
dont il reste qu'une cazaurang ne
regardais même
même avec deux pièces en pinçant de
l'échiquier il c'est très difficile pour
le roi noir retrouver des cases donc il
a qu'un seul coup a pas trop le choix
alors maintenant comment on peut faire
pour le pousser encore un peu plus oui
on peut par exemple on amène la dame ici
oui on a plaisir possibilités ça
ressemble méthodes vous voyez sauf
qu'elle euro participe aussi tout de
suite et voilà ça coince encore un peu
plus donc le roi par exemple venir sur
cette case là on continue il n'y a pas
de raison regardez juste et factures
faire attention de ne pas faire patte
c'est à dire où il n'y a pas d'échec que
le roi ne plus de cases et la partie
terre mais par mathieu nul ça s'est
farouchement comme les erreurs comme ça
donc fait soyez très attentif très
concentré on est à faire match nul
alors regardez ça peut aller très vite
maintenant parce que si le roi noir
jouent ce coup là regardez là il ya
maintenant deux coups il suffit d'amener
le roi regarder sur la case c4 regardez
toujours comment le roi un contrôle
parfaitement et la danoise vers les 16e
ranger et l'adami s'ils contrôlent donc
le roi en a plus qu'une case et là on
situations typiques de vis-à-vis
entre les deux rois le roi blanc donc
empêche le roi noir absolument de monter
ici sur ces cases l'a donc suffit de
faire un échec sur ce étrangers pour
qu'ils les maths vous voyez le truc donc
en fait il suffit d'amener la dame
voilée
donc il suffit de jouer le coup damas 5
et voilà c'est matt ont fait à la fois
oui tu sois dans b4 aussi échec comme ça
et le roi blanc ici contrôler ces cases
donc ici c'est bien matt autre
possibilité c'est de faire le baiser de
la mort on met la dame direct ici
regardez ça se voie directe
l'ademe protégé par notre roi la dame
est protégé tranquille par pardon par le
roi blanc ici donc le roi noir est en
échec de la dame et ne peut pas monter
sûr qu'une de ses cases là qui sont
contrôlés parfaitement par le roi et
aussi par la dame qui les maths aussi
c'est le baiser de la mort voilà fois
qu'on a vu oui on a vu ces deux matches
c'est facile finalement oui faire
attention à ceux à ce fameux pattes qui
peut survenir si on se trompe
vous pouvez vous entraîner et oui le sel
risque pratiquement c'est bien sûr après
par exemple si vous ne laissez pas la
dent si vous ne mettez pas juste à côté
droit il peut prendre à part ça le c'est
l'erreur possible en général c'est faire
patte donc comme on disait toujours
pensé qu'il faut une case au roi adverse
si vous jouez trop vite ça arrive
souvent quand même ça arrive les erreurs
côté estimé que ça paraît si vous faites
un 8,8 des parties où il y avait 2 5
minutes par joueur pour jouer toute la
partie mais on joue vite et parfois mais
là on peut oublier le pat donc ça serait
un peu dommage de gâcher une position
gagnante pour un pacte vais je crois
qu'on a fait le tour pour se maintenir
oi et dames relativement facile à faire
quand même
iliad a entraîné vous faut s'entraîner
parce que de s'entraîner et ainsi on
veut bien comprendre le principe il vaut
mieux s'entraîner à le faire faut pas
hésiter à passer du temps passé quelques
quelques minutes à bien comprendre le
principe et vous voyez que c'est assez
facile quand même et que grosso modo on
y arrive assez vite merci nino pour
cette leçon sur le mat avec roy et dames
merci aux airois remet au revoir à
bientôt sur des gonades tv
[Musique]